search for the gunman in a shooting at a
hookah bar is ongoing one man died more
than a dozen others hurt when gunfire
broke out after 3 a.m saturday morning
and tonight 8 news now reporter madison
kimbrough spoke to a security guard who
works at that lounge which is now closed
madison this person says this all could
have been prevented were they working
when the actual shooting happened though
yeah no but he is fully aware of how
things operate at the lounge saying that
the owner had every opportunity to make
sure his customers and staff are safe
but never followed through
people started fighting and guns got
pulled out that's that's the
neighborhood that's what happens a
shooting saturday morning at manny's
glow ultra lounge in the central valley
leaves one man dead and 13 people hurt
david a security guard at the hookah
lounge was not there at the time of the
shooting but says he reached out to the
owner with concerns before i'm not
surprised all this happened i've been
trying to talk to the owner about
getting some more real security guards
instead of his friends david says the
lack of qualified security guards made
this place an easy target for something
like this to happen i was the only
dependable security guard there everyone
else
either wasn't a security officer or was
a convicted felon
or they just wanted to play the part
security officer stating that basic
security measures such as pat downs and
using a metal detector wand did not take
place some people who work nearby say
while the shooting is tragic it's
nothing new for the area it comes with
the neighborhood
obviously this isn't the best part of
the city while others who have been
around for years say otherwise i'm not
so sure it's the area itself
this particular incident is just from
the people it brought in
now we briefly spoke to the owner of the
hookah lounge on the phone who responded
with no comment thus saying that he is
letting the police handle it as for the
victim 33 year old demetrius beard david
says he believes he was an employee of
the lounge in the newsroom madison
kimbrough live local now